hi guys my name is Iman I also go by
Pokey and these are my essentials like I
actually can't live without these if you
take them away
[Music]
don't give me too many I will eat them
all these are my guilty pleasure like so
much so that I ask them to bring them to
me because I try not to keep too many in
my house I will devour them
I've always really liked flaming hot
Cheetos in particular not the right the
big ones I want them flaming like it
hurts so good kind of spicy you know can
I have some
oh also the only downside is obviously
your fingers can get a little
dusty but what I see a lot of my friends
do is we'll just use chopsticks no Dusty
fingers it's amazing
this this is called an octo buddy it's
like eight dollars on Amazon this thing
sticks to almost everything like
it's so useful you want to film
something you didn't bring a tripod
because
around a tripod this big and I like my
purses small you know no tripod fits in
a small purse so this is basically like
a tripod if I'm getting ready or I'm
doing my skincare or if I'm
in the shower I'll just stick it on the
wall so if you want to film like a
little get ready with me you could
literally take this
stick it
to the mirror and film you're good to go
hey GQ
[Music]
I used a laptop to start streaming very
very early days and then I had to save
up for a 300 second hand custom built PC
and that was my first jump in my
equipment for streaming since then
especially as it becomes your job you
know you really really want to optimize
every little thing your audio your setup
I now have a two PC setup three monitors
two mics two keyboards two mice I have
so much going on and this was the big
camera upgrade that I used and since
then I just haven't looked back love it
when you stream you want to have a high
def camera but you don't want it to be
like too high def like I don't want
people out there to be able to count
every single pour I have on my skin and
a lot of high def cameras are like that
you need one that has a nice healthy
little blur
the one thing that maybe a lot of people
wouldn't guess about me because I do
game a lot I don't like to stay up late
I really don't I feel like I spend so
much time in front of a screen a lot of
blue light can make it hard to sleep I
try to counteract that by having a very
strict sleep regimen not a lot of people
know this about me obviously y'all are
in my bed but I'm a very very particular
sleeper and these are amazing they're by
m zoo I don't know they're on Amazon but
they're great because you see you have a
little eye hole so this squishy Fabric
in circulates your eye perfectly no
light is going to get through
like a little baby
I love these so much for the last one to
two years I've been a 10K steps a day
fanatic okay not every day but I really
really like getting my steps in I love
going on long walks and these are one of
the only shoes that have really really
stuck with me through that they are
salamons I always want to call them
salmon Mons
sorry but I think that's how you
pronounce them and they're so cute I
think they're meant for hiking but their
whole brand has really really really
cool looking shoes I need them cute
stylish and I can walk seven miles in
them
beautiful
I'll miss you
this out of all the items is the one
that is closest to my heart it's a pouch
from habanichi they have so many amazing
stationery I love journals pens markers
stickers I'm really really big into
journaling and this thing it holds it
all I need to bring my journals with me
everywhere it's like
addiction it keeps me sane moderately
but every single day or night I will
Journal this one's called brain dump
because
to transfer all the buzzing up here into
paper so I can sleep I also have pens
fit in here more pens fit in here
stickers fit in here everything fits in
here I have another Journal fits in here
also the pattern just makes me happy
isn't it cute
[Music]
this bad boy I know a lot of you guys
probably already know what it is you can
get this thing to be so bright like do
we need an extra light in here let me
know I got us and oftentimes you can
film the same content the same whatever
but if there's a light it captivates
people that much more and will make your
content do much much better also it's
really good for selfies I recommend it
if you know me you know I got two of the
cutest cats
I love them however the only thing about
having cats although they are I kid you
not the best thing that's ever happened
to me they leave hair everywhere and
something that unfortunately really
really ruins a fit is when it's covered
in hair I've tried every single lint
roller on the market especially those
that are portable nothing beats this one
look at this okay you can so it doesn't
get stuck on everything that you put it
near you don't have to waste one wrap
every single time and this is some of
the stickiest paper I've ever had some
lint rollers it's like what kind of tape
are you using because it's getting two
and a half hairs this one clean sweep
love it so much
okay these are two things that I've
already raved about so much but
obviously seeing as I'm in front of a
camera a lot you know my appearance my
skin it matters to quite the extent I've
tried so many pimple patches these are
the only ones put on a pimple and it
goes okay it's gonna suck up that purple
I know that's gross but that's what you
want out of a pimple patch and it's this
specifically like the invisible spot
cover because I put them on and I can
put makeup over it and it doesn't show
on camera I do it all the time on stream
but no one can tell it's great and by
the end of my stream I peel them off and
my pimples out of my face and these I do
have TMJ because I'll be gaming I'll be
conscient I don't really want to really
want kill you know what I mean and this
it's called the Thera face it does
everything and so anytime I feel tense
in the face I just give myself a little
massage and pop it off it has so many
different attachments ice hot micro
current so you can like snatch your face
up I love this thing and it's great for
travel so I can have like five devices
in one
both of them thanks for taking some time
watching the video learning more about
me the things that I love I hope hope
you guys liked them too if any of these
bring value to your life that would make
me very happy because they're very very
essential to mine thanks for watching